[Music]
hello
oh chat's open for everyone
i'll allow it
justice once say what you gotta say
get it all out your system night
oh wow you can change it now they
updated it so now i can put it
only subscribers
that's interesting subscriber only chat
as if anyone else is stumble upon this
[ __ ]
stream
although i did see members pop up more
when i did that
kind of sus tell me you're not
subscribed
hey
subscribe right now come on can we get
it
you have to be subscribed at least 20
minutes before you comment alright i'm
switching to members
bye
hopefully it'll calm down it has enough
data yet
there it is and it's equally fast
god dammit members
what happened to my nose i wore glasses
this morning that's what happened
and look i have a unibrow now can you
see it
where'd it go here it is
unibrow so sexy this with my csc when
kissy
where'd it go it's a stupid light we're
like what even just a little bit unibrow
nah let's go
the [ __ ] do i have here
what is this
i have been outside you're right
i liked it i'm a summer boy
always been always has been
[Music]
so
so much a summer boy uh
how do i explain this
[Music]
so eight months of the year
i would always just be at home playing
video games doing whatever the [ __ ]
super nerdy
but when summer hates
chad feeling so chris to say a different
side of me come on
i would i would switch to my more
extrovert i guess during uh
during summer's music dilemma and uh
it was because i had a completely
different friend group in my uh
summer place and one time
this one girl from my class came to my
summer place
and she started i feel like i said this
but
it was just so she almost docks me she's
like but
felix is usually kind of private and shy
hair is so different
don't rap me out [ __ ] you can't tell
[Music]
jack wants another bottle flip challenge
bruh he's just gonna die
i'm gonna kill him this year murder
straight up bang bang bang
that's right run for your life
we should do a knife flip challenge no
chains
[Music]
oh yeah all right we're playing uh
poopty today
thought it was fitting since chapter two
has come out and i never actually
finished
that online and it might be fun
it's been a long time
i was camping in uk have i not talked
about that who cares
it was camping trip but it was really
nice any time i go camping in uk i'm
like all right this country is not so
bad after all
okay fine but brighton
i i'm sure i picked the worst country
city in this country
i can't say this too long neighbor in my
tear right that sucks
we kept looking at the weather while we
were traveling
and it was so hot and lovely it was
almost like i don't even feel like i'm
in uk now
but uh we looked at the weather in
brighton [ __ ]
every time
therefore i have concluded brighton [ __ ]
it's been done
[Music]
you're welcome sorry brytonian
okay epic rant coming
epic rant here it is reason why brighton
bad
okay they have lovely buildings
everywhere right beautiful architecture
victorian
buildings amazing but right next to
any building you can find in brighton
that is pretty you have some
cheap ass building that building what
like the 70s
and it looks like actual dog [ __ ] and an
eyesore
it's the worst
it just makes you sick looking at it
it's so ugly and it's always
right next to these historical buildings
and it's like what
who allowed this why do i have to look
at this because someone else decided to
build this
i don't know why it upsets me so much
second scaffolding there's always
scaffolding
everywhere go to brighton and find one
street that doesn't have scaffolding on
it
what is up with it there's a scaffolding
conspiracy there's scaffolding
everywhere
you can never even enjoy the the
buildings because they always have
scaffolding on them
it's a conspiracy
i've never seen a country that has so
much scaffolding as uk
i hate it i hate the noise it makes
i hate everything about it i hate
scaffolding
always scaffolding scaffolding oh and
another thing
that the shitty buildings that they
build
i understand people need housing but
they're ugly
okay don't have to make them ugly
but they always call them something
to match the victorian nature of the
city so like
they have the most hideous building that
looks like a pile of turd
and they call it like the royal court
i'm like you're not fooling anyone all
right this is the royal [ __ ]
hate it
i don't like it
you guys don't know what scaffolding is
i know
english more than you first time
see you're lucky you know if you don't
know i can't tell if you're meaning and
i'm pronouncing it wrong
all right i want to sound like a boomer
i could go on but it bothers me
how ugly but then you go out in the
countryside you can a lot of the
villages
housing is preserved and it's beautiful
i love it countryside uk great
very nice and some have no scaffolding
everywhere i don't know how they do it
[Music]
don't even get me started on the i360
all right i'm ending this all right
we're playing poop d
hell yeah
i got white hair i don't but thank you
it's just little reflection of my hair
gel on
white lights okay you understand
i'm not turning white hair i'm 31
okay it's not happening my diet has
literally not a single gray hair
in his hair and it's not so it's not
going to happen to me either
okay
it does get a little blonder during the
summer told you summer boy
eyesore 360. woohoo
they don't even lit it up so we have
this tower in in brighton
that they built using taxpayer money by
the way
good choice thank you i'm glad i got a
saying that
it's supposed to be a tourist attraction
where you go up in this [ __ ] glass
blob but the glass is bent so you can't
really see outside without reflections
disturbing the view
half of it is looking out just over the
ocean and half of it is looking out
over a beach city like what's what's
there to look at
there's no toilets in it so once you go
up there you're [ __ ]
it's a gr it's gray it's ugly and they
don't even lit it up you know how they
lit up
like the paris a eiffel tower
on certain occasions oh cool they don't
do that because
somehow british airways got involved so
they only lit up blue and red
because that's the color of the airline
and they can't just like oh it's pride
month maybe we can do like a rainbow no
they don't even do that
british airways homophobes i'm calling
it
do something fun with it it's so ugly
okay i hate ugly things there we go
rent's done switch it over
the thing with ugly architecture is that
it's just there
and it's always going to be there and
everyone's going to have to look at it
and i get
why don't i get to saying it nah
no one asks hey felix do you want to
look at that no it's just there
okay i don't like it
i don't like our ugly architecture i
don't like it
here's something not ugly poopy
hell yeah
it's been a while sport game
let's go best game okay let's start the
intro here and then i have
my uh i'll switch over in a sec
very very deep oh the voice acting is so
good
lived a little worm no one cared about
poop d was his name
everyone was always laughing at poopty
because of his farting problem
poor poopdy ashamed and humiliated
he dug himself a little harder i
remember recording this pond of
tears but suddenly in the hopeless pit
an unexpected stranger appeared hell
yeah don't be sad
i'm the mighty poop duck i have come to
tell you not to be afraid little poopty
don't withhold your farts you will give
birth to great america
i'm cracking up doing the lines dark
spells from its
bathroom don't like them vicious
creatures are walking through the lands
things are about to change my tiny hero
but remember with big poop comes
big
perfect delivery perfect lines
perfect game
glad you left that stinky pitch gel now
eat three carrots and read the poop
scroll
all right so i'm emulating this on a pc
so so it's a little awkward to play but
i think it'll do
[Music]
i don't think i need one more carrot and
then we can poop
have i have i failed already did i miss
a carrot are you serious
oh my god wait what
[Music]
wait can i attack i forgot if i can
attack
no i need to poop first holy [ __ ] i play
this two minutes ago
how did i mess this up hold up
oh i need a scroll that's right all
right i'm getting ahead of myself
[Music]
wow pewdiepie sounds just like the
characters warm inside and out though
not as soft as it seems
good for close range combat and moving
obstacles
time to trust your gut feeling
and bring wonders to life press the
button
okay poop dog i press
[Music]
this is diablo music we went for kind of
the same vibe yeah
it's a really good soundtrack attacked
the poop attacks to poop
that way ronnie
poop coin clever name
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh okay never mind i was thinking i
would switch over but we can play a
little bit more
[Music]
so uh for those who don't know poop d is
a game
[Music]
that uh when did the first one came out
like two years ago
a year ago that must be two years ago
chapter two is out now that's why we're
playing it
it's been rated by some the greatest
game of all time
[Music]
it's made by our lovely polish team
amazing people
and it's free to play
i was thinking when i get to chapter two
that i invite the devs on and we can
they can talk a little bit
about the game as well i think that
could be really fun
so the game is free to play but it's
made with the intention that you don't
actually have to spend money to complete
it
it is possible but you know
[Music]
gotta make that dinner or somehow
it's not a sperm no it's a worm thank
you very much
here we go
[Music]
oh he was just very
vermin in the garden and clay plantation
of bucklers okay so here
hold up let me just switch over the
so i paid to remove ads and
i stuff know if you get ads on an
emulated version though let's see
[Music]
main menu yes
the kidnapping of edgar rescue butt dog
edgar
oh that poor little thing don't know if
i want to rescue him
there we are in poop town
we have russell waltz frostwolds grocery
very nice as you can see there's poops
but the reference is everywhere i love
it
so this is marzia martia's library
they did marzia dirty mate
you can buy a scroll pack explo fart
power farm how far we'll wait with this
i don't think we need in the beginning
here's edgar's ball
we need to go to the east gate there's
also gambling
[Music]
that's right pewdiepie promotes gambling
a lot of ticket for a magnificent
jam it's just 30 coins feeling lucky nah
nah don't gamble kids bad for you let's
go
might say look fine all right
[Music]
all right no comment need two poops to
cross
easy thank you attack my children
so the carrots and random items are to
make
poops and you use the poops
to gather more resources for poop
it's like a weird minion controller
[Music]
that's gonna take a while
it's it is a mobile game i'm using an
android emulator
[Music]
i can call them with my butthole
oh that's so nasty i mean he has a
talent
i'll give him that
[Music]
the poops looks cute yeah marcia loved
the i remember showing her the poops the
first time
[Laughter]
they're amazing
[Music]
new witcher yeah
i don't really have to clear out all
this stuff i just kind of feel like it
there we go
[Music]
a strange duck with an aura of gold
visit me visited me in my dream
and mentioned you'd come take this
powerful fart scroll please
it will save you much crawling and has
no use in the wild
bog speed town fart a gas portal to poop
town
and back pure magic with some green peas
amazing
so for five coins you can make a portal
back to uh
the town
all right i don't think we have to do
that now we can go further
[Music]
have you seen the game swan chernobyl
unexplored ooh that sounds fun
[Music]
why not show me a cool horror game today
it was uh called walk
it was like a short in the japanese
horror game it looked really cool
i might play that it's only a couple
[Music]
minutes
and in minecraft this stream
there's a new episode coming up soon
and things get very exciting i actually
found out what's new in the update
[Music]
we're writing for this game it leads
here i agree
i remember apple removed this remember
that they removed it from the
the store because they thought it was
too offensive or something
like come on they corrected it but still
like
bro all right let's not do these
highlight of the night buttocks horn
this game is amazing thank you
actually works really well on pc not
gonna lie using blue stacks
[Music]
play this on the train come from school
nice
[Music]
the game starts off with not that many
enemies but it gets
progressively more difficult here we got
some fighting
go forth my minions we might
lose some poop here not gonna lie nah
we're good we're good
i have a washboard bonus inside yeah i
watched it
um i've been listening to the soundtrack
it's really good
[Music]
i didn't like it at first but then the
more i uh listened and watched the more
i liked it
[Music]
okay we got edgar down here i don't know
where i'm going here there's a lot of
secrets and stuff in this game
it's worth looking around
i know i passed by some axolotl in the
the last video the reddit has made their
main mission in life to tell me about it
i found i recorded another video and i
found it oh
a lot of stuff all right
[Music]
a button get it what it do
i have to sacrifice one poop to open
here nice
all right no i don't okay
[Music]
oh god there's a lot of them oh it's a
spawner [ __ ] we might lose some poop
here
oh gotta poop another one oh we lost two
poops
that's in the chat poop out new ones
go forth my minions we gotta kill that
green thing as soon as possible
oh god they're poison my poops are
poison god damn it
yes this is a mobile game oh god but
they got poison too oh excellent
oh it's not a spawner it was a trap i
forgot oh well
it's fine another poop day
there will be zero dash but not zero
poop dabs i'll guarantee that
oh god
[Music]
music is very nordic well yeah it's like
the
diablo style i'm not sure what nordic
music is to be honest
[Music]
it looks like butters yeah you're right
a little bit a wee bit like butters mate
there's that gary we got him
[Music]
yeah the poops are so cute you kind of
feel bad when they die but then again
they are poops
okay we got a big battle coming up
are we ready yes we are go forth poop go
go go go next one
oh god the big ones do so much damage oh
god oh god
abort abort come back no no
don't come to me
[Laughter]
he's gonna die go help your brother
help help him oh my god
all right we got him
two more if they team up they're strong
wait did i lose another one oh [ __ ] say
yes who says yashi every time he kills
anything puppy
is that what you mean because the answer
is nah oh wait we got more to clear out
of here
this one too might
do i have to kill if i get up
oh i can't
i love ads on live streams are there ads
in this video
no way what the [ __ ]
[Music]
youtube works i get ads
get out of here i like how the poop
looks like barrels
nice detail even the cage is a shape of
a poop
[Music]
all right you're free but that guy
you're free
woof-woof what [ __ ] it's me edgar thank
you
thank you for saving me okay i now
return
and we'll reward you in town let's go a
little further we can get some stuff
[Music]
anyone here likes dolphin great question
matthias mathias
might show me how what sea land sea sea
fish
sea dolphins look like and i think it's
time to kill them
i'm done with dolphins they're too ugly
to live i'm sorry
see dolphins i'm sorry no you're full
whoa what do we got here
is that it friendly or not that's
friendly
[Music]
i don't think i get ads because i'm
emulating
[ __ ] yeah i just get pooped
you're not getting any money out of me
oh we need three poops here but we only
have to poop
what do you do all right let's remember
that
[Music]
where's that on the map there okay
yeah i got a premium youtube account i
don't know if i'm actually paying for it
or youtube just gave it to me
that's how they get you with
subscriptions though but it is actually
worth it
uh got a poop you mean a beluga is that
what they were
no belugas are cute it was a it wasn't a
balloon
thank you for asking them
[Music]
oh that's a trap a crap trap run poops
run
yeah ain't going to kill me
[Music]
return oh another trap a crap that
we're good that was close
[Music]
what do you mean sea dolphin isn't that
just office no dolphins that don't live
in the ocean but they live in the sea
[Music]
they look like these butts actually kind
of not gonna lie
what river sorry river
marshall clarified river dolphins thank
you
[Music]
did it crash oh [ __ ] no
no that's what you get for emulating i
guess
god damn it oh god please tell me it's
saved though
it i think it did
no it's not a walrus a river dolphin
oh my god i'm gonna die they put me back
here
and all the monsters respawn [ __ ]
[Music]
it might be good to open a portal and
just skid idle
let's go back to edgar
[Music]
okay
[ __ ] dolphins crash the game mate all
right we gotta go
thank you for bringing edgar back i bet
that evil wizard is behind this
if you have any awful in the future hey
how's that visit
do you have any spare waffle
there you go again oh so delicious
you're welcome oh yeah give us oh yes so
yummy
poop fountain should we gamble let's go
gamble
come on give us something good
hell yeah let's go
so what's our quest now look around talk
to necroman
in poop town okay
i guess that's this horrible thing
listen i sense a sword in search of poop
coins
for the last hundred years a growing
hatred has divided the good folks of the
grams
but to keep a butt dog locked in the
gate
that is cruel to even by my twisted
stance
who would do such a thing maybe the butt
helps know
no one knows the ground better than them
so here's where you get your skills
that's right
power of your poops a freeze for 10
seconds
pretty good uh poop to get an additional
heart
yeah let's go with that
moves faster okay yeah
[Music]
uh poop limit absolutely
faster pooped [ __ ] it i'm rich all right
[Music]
find tom but the butt health
i think this is supposed to be
jacksepticeye yeah
nice always the soiling on my heart
your sister marcia twin butter
what you're getting one he was like a
father to me i loved him like my son
oh you're good
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're getting two no don't look at me
like that i'm sorry i have to poop
no
[Music]
please do not google river dolphins i
told you bro they gotta go
they had their chance
they had their chains and they ruined it
[ __ ] you dog river dolphins
to the ruins of bro poop the greatest
poop of all
[Music]
now this game has nothing to do with
poop what are you talking about
gotta collect their dirty work
[Music]
can i go here why can't that oh i got a
room that's in all right fine
where's ken now has he not told you what
he's doing
[Music]
they're endangered uh [ __ ] it they lived
enough how many millions of years do we
need species to be alive all right
come on
[Music]
you had your you had your time river
dolphin all right i'm sure you lived a
long time but now it's over
you're done you're done i'm joking by
the way
it's not obvious but still am i i don't
know
[Music]
they're pink
but kind of sexy all right now i'm
ending this conversation
i'm making another poop you guys are too
gross
uh when so we need to find the butt else
was that it
i'll find tom about to butt out we saw
him before then
diablo reference you guys see it
what does this guy sell like
who assumes being good we'll see you
later
[Music]
okay everybody i have to go here
need some more poops are you right
[Music]
i don't know how we missed that one
all right we cleared out this area
[Music]
with some respawn
i need to go down here is it worth going
i don't know
[Music]
already full of hearts baby
sudden google search spike for river
dolphins
i need four poops can i make four
i think i can nope come on
i can let's go for poops gang
yeah baby rich gang
poop gang baby let's go
[Music]
that's kind of cool you need less if you
go from the other end
did i not grab everything here i can do
it again because oh it crashed that's
why i didn't
speaking of crashing maybe i should say
[Music]
i think it's down here maybe no
it says nearly up there okay
[Music]
you got no change my
the game mode is delayed really are you
sure
how do you know
[Music]
oh god i gotta kill these strong ass
[ __ ]
i think we lost the poop
i need to upgrade a second poop faster
[Music]
poop limit has been reached hold up
matt oh we need to go down
wondering how many people are pooping at
the same time
now we're asking the intellectual
questions sophie i'm glad you asked
there has to be a way to calculate this
if everyone poops once a day
and there's nine billion people on
planet
as that's a lot of poop man this is a
[Music]
lot
there are no poop in the shower
references in this game thank you very
much
all right we gotta get past these geese
says all right
send one return
[Music]
just as planned
send one send one return
[Music]
send one return
[Applause]
[Music]
can't trap the trap master
my girlfriend has this much food
following her too i'm not sure
i understand well you're saying to be
honest
i should play this in the shower why
explain logic make no sense
i love that they have a guitarist
combined with farts yeah they
really nailed it
[Music]
oh dangerous return
is that a trap we're going through we're
going through all in oh my god it was a
trap
a double trap oh no
poop i should have learned it into go go
go
oh this is terrible oh my god i can't
fight him oh trap him come here
idiot dumb this is how you were supposed
to do that
dumb dumb butt
yeah it came out it's still like it's
available in ios
they corrected their mistakes
what if the game actually takes place in
poop shower dream hmm
now you're talking the real lore
because it is hidden
where it takes place so you're thinking
the right way
i see we have some intellectuals in the
chat today
gotta hand it to you
god damn these are strong
[Music]
what does this do again you don't have
required poop that just happens
sometimes
[Music]
behold
jacksepticeye sock let's get it
all right we're through let's find his
butt out
[Music]
oh trap
[Applause]
nah
[Music]
he's gotta be he's just gotta be
oh god maybe i should learn to the trap
come back come back learn to the trap
ow i am poisoned now good job
[ __ ] the poison is the worst go
you can do it i believe four versus one
let's go
coin does sound like the next script
[Music]
well that'd be great i'll be rich to tom
bud perfect let's go
[Music]
cozy vibe i like the music
i realize i just sounded like that bro
burning skit
the music is great here i love it tom
butt
oh i didn't notice yet my bad hi i'm
time yeah
yeah all right i was testing a brand new
melodious fart when a nasty green
creature tore my score apart
jackseptic
fart bring me back my symphony
or i we'll be in agony
combat symphony find the three rolls of
symphony
will do tom but anything to stick it to
that
rhythm but an impart in fart
what did it all mean
uh sometimes when foreigners come to
sweden
we have these signs that say in part
which is basically i mean like
driveway or like enter entry
and people think it's hilarious you
fools
[Music]
entertained by in farts so childish
ah ah we're good
what is this ribbon butt in part
okay
check septic tank hey
hey let's go let's go
very good there's one symphony we got it
all right just gotta get it
i like my own parts to be honest now why
would you share that
i mean obviously but why would you all
right
i'm hungry dude [ __ ] i just had lunch
i'm gonna get a snack
[Music]
[Applause]
let me park at the end part hey
oh it's poison don't have to fight it
just let it die
it did
yeah die slow painful dead
yeah stupid butt but
do be kind of sexy though
[Music]
pro move right there oh
oh god they're dying so fast we're good
[Music]
okay everyone attack
let's go four together strong poop i
like it
you like it
where the [ __ ] did i just go don't tell
me i walked in circles
[Music]
riven but
are there butts riven but let's not go
to rhythm
[Music]
[ __ ] that response to monsters god damn
it why'd i do this
[Music]
oh god it's coming
no go on the button
there we go unlike shortcut
hell yeah
this is skyrim
this is ellen ring leaked ellen ring
oh god evelyn likes
evelyn ring looks mad
looks insane
[Music]
ah [ __ ] we're gonna have to die now
all together now
there we go
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is a symphony
how do i get there though must be secret
somewhere
so far sarah lamps i will say that oh we
got another ad
excellent [ __ ] i gotta pee and i gotta
get snack and then we'll be back
[Music]
oh god there's so many enemies here
let's see if we can just click on him no
we can't we got to go through that man
you know what we're going to do that
later all right can i pause
let's go right back speed run
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
oh you waited for me thank you is that
world record
i wonder what the fastest pa p was
it's got to be so fast do you count it
as
the most amount of p per second or is it
just like
because that fast piece is a drizzle and
that doesn't count as fast p
that's a question something to think
about
[Music]
what are your thoughts
that was really bad i know
i wash my hands i need a japanese hand
wash where you just
put water on your hands to pretend that
you washed them
[Music]
[Applause]
you should add you can see how much
damage the poop says
that's actually a good suggestion thank
you burner
[Music]
it's always fun to see how much damage
they do
[Music]
and this pandemic is it mandatory to
wash hands properly
okay
[Music]
what do i do man i'm gonna compute all
day we're gonna do
[Music]
is that a protein bar yes the greatest
snack of all time
cookie and cream flavor
[Music]
arkham
thank you appreciate yeah that's very
kind of you
[Music]
we're playing poop d the greatest game
of all time out on ios and android check
it out
new chapter 2 available
[Music]
[Applause]
favorite cereal kids i don't need cereal
it's too unhealthy but
i'll tell you what the best is
[Music]
my granddad's recipe you take corn
flakes sour milk
[Music]
raisins and cinnamon and you got
yourself a bombast
um breakfast
[Music]
oh yeah i'm not doing this this is not
chapter two i'm playing chapter one
because i i never
finished it online and i thought it'd be
fun to do that
[Music]
but it was a while since i played so
how much protein i think 20 grams
probably i'm glad you asked
it doesn't [ __ ] say 20 grand
these are proven way more difficult to
find than i thought
hey we got this stand
bruh raisins get so much [ __ ]
everyone like reading
it's motherflipping delicious okay what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you oh i don't
like saying
something that tastes a little weird
it's good
it's amazing it's sweet as [ __ ]
hell
you can just stuck your mouth forward is
good raising good you don't want your
racing
[ __ ] it i'll eat raise my raisins i'll
eat your rating
more raisins for me it's much a
what are you doing like raisins eat the
raisins raising good
they're making me fart like [ __ ]
crazy though i will say that
but raising good
there's a stigma
racist stigma needs to broke
you don't like them huh well fine more
racist for me
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
now what are those bigger looking racing
things adults
or whatever they call in english i don't
like them
raising them
[Music]
oh my cookie has raisins in it i don't
like it anymore
grow me a river my radio
raisins are just sugar
so that's why you don't need it that's
why it's a problem in your cookie
[Applause]
don't try and explain this by explaining
it because you can't explain
science no don't go in there poison you
dumb poop
dates thank you
don't like them
here's a dress the sour milk some people
say it's buttermilk i don't know what it
is
we call it phil milk in sweden
which means file file milk
i don't i don't know i don't know okay
[Music]
doing great here by the way i almost got
our first poop scroll
this is huge so many trends
[Music]
racing's bad i can't believe people are
saying this you're breaking my heart
do you think we can just run through i
think we can
let's go oh god we gotta kill these
fast nice now
kill it
nice and no one got poisoned
dates with cheats
that's disgusting how dare you
[Music]
okay let's go through the poop doll
like i was floating it's beautiful here
[Music]
oh nice norway gang love you piss thank
you martha
[Music]
so in my other video i complained that
sweden
let go of norway and then they found all
the oil but apparently norway offered
the oil
[Music]
half of it to sweden for volvo or
something i don't know if this is true
because if it is i'm so angry at sweden
because sweden sold vulva to china
which is the mo yeah and is that
what why you do this
[Music]
god damn it sweden
god damn you sweden i'm done i'm
canceling you
i'm adding sweden to cancel list right
next to river dolphins
[ __ ]
you're done norway better alright i'm
switching over norway gang
i'm the region now that's how that works
we gotta kill these fans
otherwise there's a wee bit you shave on
my
[Music]
no don't go there don't go there
one way of poisoning all it takes my
[Music]
ah there's the first one [ __ ] they're
difficult again
all right let's call one come back
okay those butts looks insanely strong
how can i kill them
i can use these traps right
let's do that and come back
okay we got to kite them now right
through here
[ __ ] one of our poops went in oh this
bad
oh this is real bad uh we're trapped
am i going to die i think this might be
it
[ __ ]
we got a distraction make them go
through the fart
there it is
[Music]
oh thank god oh he dropped the poop
scroll
did i not poop oh god
all right we'll just cut more of them
luckily i'm faster
this game has intense battle strategy
straight
strategy strategy stride
stretch one poop
come on you can do it you can do it i
knew we could do it
i knew we could do it
he out here he doing it
[Music]
did i not get the poops bro are you
serious mate
no don't go there don't go there
go through the poison dammit
come back come back oh god they're
trapped
save them ow
come here come here come here my
pooplings
[Music]
no no
they're all gonna die final battle oh
god i only got eight poops left this is
terrible
kaiden kill him
[Applause]
oh my god go to me
so dumb
[Applause]
come on come on let's go super strong
poop
that was tough dude sheesh
i can make it so i can heal my poops
later
i think i'll do that when we're back in
town
[Music]
you got a poop scroll
felix the shower guy yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right here we go
how far
all right we can heal our poops
this is huge if only
if only in real life okay honest
question
you have to answer honestly have you
ever taken a picture of your poop
yes or no only honest answers please
[Music]
don't waste my time lying
i'm waiting for answers yes
ill yeah what's wrong with the l how
could you do that
the only valid answer is yes come on
come on
[Music]
have you ever taken a picture of your
poo and sent to someone
yes
i think i've done it to ken actually
once i'm sorry ken i don't know why i
did that
yeah i'm that guy is anyone surprised
huh
let's heal these babies
let's go watch that ad
get get that guy
so savior
[Music]
for the doctor oh my god i've done that
too actually oh gosh
[Music]
let's run on the poop trail i had to
show my poop to the doctor because there
was
like a tiny bit of blood in it
and i figured better early cash
blood poop than later blood catch poop
you know what i'm saying
[Music]
but i have so many embarrassing stories
classic neighborhood kids move yep
that's me
[Music]
have you ever had to poop in a jar for a
doctor no but something tells me you
have to had do that damien
what the [ __ ] mate that's bloody
disgusting heal
there it is my poops never die
it's cool combat is really picking up
[Music]
did the doctor diagnose your poop with
gamer yeah
that's basically what she said
yeah music is [ __ ] great too a little
biased but you know
a little bi said get it swedish gamer
get it good job
how have i not gone to the center or
sandra's at the bottom
[Music]
okay
okay how many poops do we need to do
this quest
[Music]
oh big battle inside
i love that intense
intensity of healing your poops
super hardcore
[ __ ] it's on cool down
[Music]
this way safer so far sure this i will
say that
pretty proud
sound effects are great dude all right
one poop there one put there another
poop there go forth my poop legs
we got ai on the poops they know how to
walk there
or so i thought all right
all right mate one of yes
it was [ __ ] one of yours oh one of
them did oh
[ __ ] no no you stay
stupid poops stay
no you stay everyone stay
stay in your stations
thank you yes
uh-oh kill them fast boys
you're not killing them fast at all
now consequence [ __ ] they're going all
over the place
now this
[Music]
let's go we got a gem a fart jam
okay we gotta go back for the scrolls
all right did i pick it up i can't
remember if i picked it up [ __ ] sake
all right there's something on the map
[Music]
anyway
some of them respawn it's just
is
[Music]
they're weak anyway pathetic
okay
poop scroll down here let's get it
through the portal
yeah all the monsters have names i i
don't remember them
all right this one on here on the left
apparently so will he recognize that we
got one of them
no i guess we need all of them
why are you guys asking me about shampoo
right what
i'm not doing shampoo what the [ __ ]
shutting that down i cannot have a rumor
of me making shampoo be true
however big day today new gpu will
flavor up
[Music]
it's coming out today at the 5 p.m i
think
or 3 p.m
[Music]
we get a new spell
yeah the game is very cute oh so they're
scrolls
so they told me not to show them before
and then i've had literally had them in
the background on my videos
[Music]
you're gonna get 30 off with code
pewdiepie as well
very nice yuzu japanese lemon
[Music]
very nice
i have very active finally a new flavor
super super excited i'm dying
oh i can heal i can heal my poops but i
can't heal myself
this is so sad
classic old school gaming kiting
happening here
damn it they're dying
[Music]
oh he's getting destroyed oops too
strong
so will the scroll be in here yes baby
one more eye yes
[Music]
shampoos okay i like that idea actually
is it sour no i don't think so usually
it's kind of sweet actually
does that make sense i don't know it's
hard to describe
and new shakers let's go they
always sell out
this gave me some ps4 in our ps5
exclusive
[Music]
ah [ __ ] off man there you go
trap crab trap yeah it's citrusy
that's right you got it it's really good
i think we're doing um
calorie calorie um caffeine free one as
well which i'm really excited about
aversion that is that okay we gotta look
through
[Music]
do you them just the best
bruh okay look at my face
[Music]
so i drank these [ __ ] free
pre-workouts right everyone's saying g
fuel is pre-workout but it it [ __ ]
isn't
but so i i tried uh pre-workout and my
face i don't know if you've seen my
videos the past couple of weeks they've
just been
pizza face i've been breaking out like a
[ __ ] teenager
and as soon as i stopped my face cleared
up
i'm sticking with you do you feel for
for life all right never had that
problem
would you feel do you feel best okay
legit same thing happens if i'm
traveling and i don't have g fuel with
me and i buy an energy drink
skin just go no you teenager now
and what i'm saying is
do you feel bad everything else no oh
god i mix that
everything else bad jesus
oh what a wonderful gift you bring can
we
where soon i will again sing edgar has
been taken you say
then seek out butter jill for help right
away
that was lit
fine butter deal what is the reference
there let's kill us
uh [ __ ] your violin or whatever it is
do not clip me saying g feel bad i will
murder you
you hear me i would never say that
all right
[ __ ] i don't have the required poop yet
i'm really excited for chef to play
chapter two of this
it's fun uh i actually don't know
anything about chapter two
they showed me and i gave feedback on
the this one but
not the not the next chapter
i'm sure there will be some surprises
riven but we found it
this is where the elves live the butch
elves
oh that looks creepy as hell what the
[ __ ] i ain't going there
the new g field is not out yet in a
couple hours it's coming out
uh-huh okay
[Music]
big map man goddamn
okay thank god that isn't poisonous
[Music]
to the murky butlin hmm yes
all right let's check this out
[Music]
go away you stink rude
and then i got a statue identical
[Music]
amazing oh the beautiful
the one and only my bird told me you
will come
little one somebody poisoned the city my
fountain
edgar's kidnapped kidnapper may have
been involved
would you be so kind and check the riven
butt as well well
oh the well sorry poisoned well check
the nearby well in rhythm then
we'll do my queen anything for queen
kill this though
[Music]
we're playing poop d it's out on ios and
android check it out it's free to
[Music]
download
no this is not marching that would be
funny though that might say is uh the
old lady in the game
give me the poop scrubs really detail
like
there's a lot of hidden nooks and
crannies in this game
[Music]
[ __ ] chairs in the way mate
is mars in the second chapter oh i don't
know that's what i was saying i
have no idea oh power fart finally
ancient gangsters unleashed in the city
of bro poop
increase the attack of your team with
the fumes of brave
ancestors
we've all been there we've all done that
[Music]
such a silly sound what the [ __ ]
worth it i'm getting a call from
brighton oh god do you think they heard
my
[Music]
rant
sorry i had to take the call my bad
brighton just called to cancel me they
heard my rant
and they told me to leave and i said
fine i am leaving
[ __ ]
[Music]
i hurt the chair poor chair
[ __ ] you chair i'm good oh what jay
it is actually worth getting this stuff
[Music]
i hope that people like g fuel on
aggregates there's no way they're made
there's no way
it's just a wee bit laugh mate don't be
so serious
[Music]
i saw that uh darman responded to me
he uh if you remember me and ken reacted
to one of his videos
[Music]
and uh he put my video in his video
it was really funny i don't know why
it made no sense
i thought i i mean i probably was a
little grumpier and
and harsher than i would have been
normally but i just
thought there was such a bad
i i'm just like i have nothing against
uh
face reign or whatever and darmin like
not trying to do some beef or but
whatever but
this is funny to me
it's just we beat laughs mate it's not
serious
[Music]
i've been watching gordon ramsay that's
why i keep doing [ __ ] dumb ass accent
that is
super cringe
[Music]
thoughts on frenemy's ending i heard
about that
when i was camping is anyone surprised
it's like you work with trisha paytas
it's bound to happen sooner or later
this is a poison oh
he poisoned my part i hope you're proud
of yourself piece of [ __ ]
i can unlock stefano here hmm don't
think i remember that
thanks for the bro ted
oh god they [ __ ] no they're all gonna
die you're all gonna die i'll heal you
i'll heal you i'll tell you they're
not gonna you live you live they live
[Music]
god i hate them
oh god super strong this bad
oh god uh go
poop already
[Music]
let's go strong poops go forth oh oh god
it's a spawner kill the spawner
god damn this is a tough fight ah
but worth it look at this
have you ever watched little gordon no
but i i was curious because he always
looks the same age
he looks like he doesn't age he just has
the same old space
uh so we're curious how we look like
young it looks way different
uh but we're watching the show that it's
like from 2008 or something
[Music]
is it going to hatch oh [ __ ] it what is
this dark souls
what the [ __ ] is that get out of here
boopty just like dark souls i knew it
[Music]
and a new anime you're watching felix
thank you for asking
uh a recommendation from ken
kobayashi dragon something
yes
it's a little bit weird real kid stuff
in it but it's really funny otherwise
[Music]
did you upgrade your boost in town no i
should really go back to town i
i'm going full out on this i'll never
get a mess
[Music]
oh ken just wrote me
he's having a rough time
[Music]
that's ken said what he's doing can
someone confirm
in the chat so i know i'm not saying
something
[Music]
rude
right he's moving okay right
[Music]
did he say where to australia okay so
you guys know
i don't know if you didn't announce it
or something and i spilled the beans
he's an all c now mate
yeah yeah i think he had a long flight
i just i can't even traveling to
australia like the most
remote place in the world during coven
sounds like a nightmare
just me going to sweden took like six
extra hours
it's like usually a two or three hour
trip
took whole day to travel it's crazy
are these rats strong i hope they're not
oh god well we're gonna find out
ah [ __ ] oh god
are they attacking me what is happening
it's attacking me ah
i can't die i'm the strong one
[Music]
okay they're not so bad
we're the kids yeah exactly traveling to
australia
during covered with kids [ __ ]
[Music]
uh let's check the map where's the
funnel then
i've clearly explored everywhere
[Music]
all right let's progress i've been here
long enough
[Music]
i watched jesus christ uh my thoughts
were
amazing animation but i i still think
i'm too old for
shonen stuff it just doesn't do it for
me anymore
[Music]
it's not to be like i'm too smart it's
just
i just feel like i've seen so much of it
and that it just feels a bit samey
the wah the wall's heavy lid opens for
the third
yes
[Music]
let's go i didn't dislike it i thought
it was entertaining
[Music]
i just didn't love it all right
what are you gonna do zoom me
i need more poops man only four poops
should we use a portal yeah i'll use a
portal i think i can use it to go back
as well how do i use portal town for it
boom so we are here
and the town and the
town is where's the town
here of course
[Music]
you encounter your kitchen have my
videos oh that's a good idea i like that
it can heal
and we can get some spells skills
need to find a new poop scroll okay what
a skill so we had nuggets
upon poop's death a nugget appear okay i
want that
grotesque necromance spell resurrecting
fallen warriors as brave nuggets
hoopty cannot control them directly okay
i forgot about that mighty poops hoops
become stronger
let's go dead poops drop some
ingredients let's go
poop gets sharp spikes additional costs
oh we can make spiky cubes
explosive part
freeze fart
how much uh
okay sure
[Music]
damn we're gonna be fast as [ __ ] boy
okay
[Music]
i think that's good for now let's do a
little bit of gambling
thanks for nothing [ __ ]
wait do i actually have to go all the
way now [ __ ]
or can i use a poop scroll
i can let's go
[Music]
what's the best beginner philosophy book
that we would recommend really wanted to
read something a bit more impacting
try some play it up bro i don't know
symposium oh
what do i usually recommend i forget
[Music]
when will the pink tsuki shirt result i
don't i have no idea
sorry
it's really difficult making ethical
clothing everything takes so much longer
[Applause]
but they will at some point
i'll tell you all right i'll let you
know
all right buff freeze
easy clamp
oh do these not require scrolls they
just
all right
[Music]
oh we're healing the water it's cool
[ __ ] miss alone
as much as i watched fruit basket i
think she'd love it yeah she really
liked it so
i watched the original when i was young
and i loved it but then we watched a
remake
which was seemed like a pretty good
[ __ ] i went in why did i go in i
couldn't stand watching it again i don't
know why
but she liked it
[Music]
where do you buy a good gun then uh oh
mine
oh good thing about brighton they have a
good gundam store i'll give them that
dave's comic salsa
[Music]
that's one for brian see not all bad
feel my children
it's the jackseptic socks those [ __ ]
poisoning the whales
there we go
right and redeem i'm just
i'm just joshing by the way i do like
brighton obviously if i've lived there a
long time i just feel like uh
[Music]
yes i'm done
save game kill
flute yes it's a flute
[Music]
what i think of eldon ring it looks
[ __ ] dumb
i'll play it i don't know if i'll get
into it but i'll definitely play it
here can we go here now yes we can baby
yes we can and we will
we can make spike poops now
[Music]
[Applause]
i sing this song while playing
so how's that
die nice
voice of an angel thanks
[Music]
i'm good how are you so next
better than yesterday i don't know if
you guys catch the 30 minute
meltdown of me not understanding discord
i apologize for that by the way
[Applause]
are they taking damage what the [ __ ] is
hurting oh my god i didn't see it
[ __ ] four poops
let's make use out of this scroll oh god
oh
whoa
oh we got the nuggets look at them
so cute what the [ __ ]
so i can't control this but i got the
spike poos nice and it's cleared
best game or what guys
so we didn't get that earlier
gotta get the covered vaccine i got my
first nose yeah
[Music]
i have a feeling you're gonna need to be
vaccinated to travel
so since i'm leaving
i want to make sure i got it all covered
working super slow and watching you help
get through the day oh that's awesome
glad to be hanging out with you guys
all right bye die
oh god they're so strong i'm almost dead
go nuggets thank you
the sound the nuggets make i don't know
if you can hear it
graphic to real make we want to poop i
will say playing this while you're in
the toilet
it is the best experience
you're right mate
[Music]
special offer
already i already purchased some
i don't think i needed but
i think in uh retrospect we were a bit
too kind with
uh the game being free because uh
[Music]
i don't know it's not like it raked in
huge amount of cash this game but
i'm really proud of it and it's really
cool
and it gives everyone chance to play
which is awesome
legit you can finish the game without
spending a dime
although might be difficult
i don't know i haven't tried it
the nuggets attack uh you're the best
thank you there you're the you're the
best
all right you're in the bed you got
200 that's very generous of you by the
way god damn
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh yeah as long as you have fun creating
it i thought you said cheating it
i was like what how dare you
all right last bit of for the fountain
or the well
trying to get whiskey lately need
another review video
i think i removed my whiskey videos
nice
none of my poops will die and neither
will i
there it is nice
[Music]
candace your mama you're seriously
trying to get me huh
[Music]
oh wait there's more oh there's one more
thank you cops appreciate that
cooking with pewdiepie video please
maybe i should make pie
see i wanted to make a pie review video
and i
i thought they would look so gross i
didn't want to want to try it
[Music]
hey get [ __ ] oh god oh god
i'm gonna die my first day not today
not today
i don't think so
save me poops
let's go yes i was on the last bit of
jacksepticeye's stock how many [ __ ]
socks does he have
[Music]
my dad used to make a cheese pie with
ham in it
i could probably make that and use fake
hem or something
that was pretty good i'll ask him for
the recipe maybe i don't know
i don't know if i feel like making a
cooking video to be honest
oh thank god i'm gonna hurt nice
me and my girlfriend love your videos so
much uh i've been a fan since your call
of duty day
don't ever plan to stop dude alex thank
you so much
all right we gotta go back clean the
water from the stinky socks i think i
did that
[Music]
did i not
oh why ah one left okay
never mind thought i was done
use real ham you zuma
bruh i real ham legit
gross i don't know why i think that
they're always so sweaty
ham is [ __ ] gross dude it's always
wet and
weird
can't change my mind
[Music]
oh god they're calling me again hold on
you couldn't hear that i just said i'll
be two minutes
any sorry nights
someone's coming to pick up some
documents and
i had to sign it
fun
we're still talking about raisins what's
going on
hell yeah john i see you
i want it don't die don't die don't die
i want it mate
did i mute the audio my bad there we go
[Music]
do you think i'm playing valeno rent
later i doubt it
[ __ ] valor right bad game
friendship with valerie over
i picked it up to play with jack but
then he stopped playing
and then i got really into him i'm like
why am i still playing this he
doesn't even play it anymore [ __ ] this
[Music]
and even then nah why are you talking
about figs
stop it get out of here all right we're
done
we did the quest
i did you dirty business
[Music]
jackson in the latest video youtube will
be collab soon
sure yeah always enjoy climbing
giant
[Music]
you were getting good though no i
[ __ ] weren't
so the socks were poisoning our water
look they've got an emblem
a green eye the mark belongs to a wizard
called smiron
nice my scouts reported that he's hiding
in the farting mountains
now that's a clever name first brewpu
falls and now this
time has come to teach smiron a lesson
palestine or israel yeah this is
definitely the
place to talk about that thank you for
asking
[Music]
uh what's your favorite sushi roll now
this is a more controversial question
that i will also not answer
[Music]
salman again okay
thank you gilbert by the way very
generous nomination
love from california love back maid
growing up on the tv while i work
throwing you up on the tv iron work cool
game thanks for hanging out hell yeah
thank you guys
thank you oh my god it's whatever
music is [ __ ] lame never noticed
[Music]
they're cooking the butts yes so we
beating a steamy
where's the stefano i know there is a
stefano in here i remember it too
actually now
this way salmon or tuna hmm
salmon in uk but obviously tuna in japan
you can't beat it
[Music]
tuna here doesn't taste very very that's
good
the salmon gets by you know
[Music]
i watch i was watching your old
playthroughs and fun the classic course
party hell yeah
butter that pooper
by far one of my faves started wondering
you'd play it again someday
no but i saw this game came out like
months ago that i have kept my eye on
it's called omori
which has that rpg style
it's great reviews i'll probably play
that
uh at some point
[Music]
because i want to play i wanted to play
another game that has rpg horror feel
i don't even know if it's a horror i
assume it is
um
do i like eel [ __ ] yeah delicious
[Music]
oh [ __ ] straps no
no go go go go go ah
oh god it's a spawner too [ __ ] this is a
disaster
kill the spawner damn it
[Music]
i'm worried it's pretty long though well
i'm streaming [ __ ] it
how long are we talking
[Music]
[ __ ] the poops are strong as hell dude
oh he's gonna die
nice if what's your best playthrough for
an rpg game
that it will always have a special place
in my heart that was such a sweet game
this one also one of the first that i
played of that stuff
and that takes me back man
all right we're here okay okay
should we go back to town maybe
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm already took 20 hours to finish are
you sure you want to stream it here
really
well i appreciate you letting me know i
if anything i want to give it a try
if i don't like it
i'll drop it did i fix your dumbbells
yeah my manager actually bought me new
ones i don't know
i thought the company sent it but it was
a nice gift
don't go in the trap
[Music]
hold on we're doing this
back to poop town
what's my daily protein intake about 20
gram per meal
and then snacking snacking smacking
you know how it is you know what it is
there you go edgar
nice manager seems rare yeah honestly
uh well they're canadian so
they're normal human beings great people
um
[Music]
makes pooping shorter yes
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
let's go
let's go let's go
[Music]
yeah i'm poor now
fine
let's gamble
yes let's go rich gang
i've been struggling with trying to
professional providers just wanted to
let you know how much
your channel has helped me through the
works of it give it a good convenience
as a nisha asunder
thank you very much i'm glad my video's
calm
[Music]
anytime i read stuff like that i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know if i believe that but
i mean if it's
true that's amazing just keep hanging in
there
um
i don't mean it and i'm like oh you're
just lying i just mean like
i don't think my videos are that great i
don't see how that's possible
[Music]
okay let's go
let's go
[Music]
what book are you reading any book i
recommend
i'm reading harry potter actually
nice and family-friendly late
have you had okonomiyaki i always wanted
to try yeah
marzia makes it she makes it pretty
regularly sometimes
regularly sometimes he's made a few
times it's really good
it's like a weird japanese pancake like
a savory pancake
like a normally really but i don't know
how to describe it it's different
i can afford a new scroll oh that's
right i can buy
these uh
okay
[ __ ] knew it there we go
damn they do a lot of damage now [ __ ]
[Music]
uh
don't die
let's wait for him to come to us
hurry hurry there we go we're fine we're
fine can i go in here
[Music]
it looks like a can oh there
let's go from here
stay
[Music]
nice
what are these questions right i guess
such random questions
i don't mind
i thought you lost interest in
playthroughs or the games don't fit your
taste nowadays
uh if i find the right game
i think that's all i need i still enjoy
it i just need to find the right game
i enjoy playing resident evil that was
[Music]
fun
okay what's what's this all about what's
all this
[Music]
oh god this looks horrible oh no
oh no i kill these
no but they can die oh
nice
[Music]
kill it dead
nice okay so we just did a shortcut
[ __ ] sake
oh we can go here
[Music]
i'm glad you guys enjoyed this cereal
too
just made me realize how [ __ ] bad i
had at games jesus christ
[Music]
wait a minute how i get there though
an exotic fruit you really like yuzu
no nugget got poison
this soul
special offer
next time
[Music]
you don't have poops like this with
spikes on them [ __ ] your guys are
missing out
[Music]
you can afford a new upgrade wait i can
upgrade from here
no way bloody hell bloody
don't go in the trap oh what did i say
god dang it
[Music]
go go go go go don't go in the trap oh
god there's another trip
oh god no no no
oh god and that's going to become a trap
[ __ ]
oh he dead stop
stop don't die
go
[Music]
nailed it
hell yeah master strategy happening
you can't contest this
literally spend a thousand poop coin
bloody hill
bloody hell bloody bonkers in it
[Music]
well what's all this thing
if you don't buy it then 50k other
people aren't gonna buy it well i i
already bought it that's why
this is a special offer if you're low on
resources
you misunderstanding may you projecting
me
god oh no oh no
all right we're just gonna have to go
for it ah
no my heart oh god i'm gonna die
oh god it's over
[Music]
oh look how many nuggets we have now
oh we have so many nuggets
oh this better be worth it
i could die here
i did it
that was tough
okay send the poops first
okay it doesn't hurt when they run back
on it it's only when it's triggered
go you dumb poopy
no don't fight there don't fight there
don't fight oh my god these traps are
horrible
oh god five poops how rich do you think
i am
they say papi
abby you
what's all this thing
[Music]
welcome my juicy lad we are survivors
from the great battle of bro poop
please excuse the mess we don't get
visitors here often
billy escaped from the poop slugs birth
which infested smaller drum
poop we look at the fire and sing old
songs
it's good that we have supplies it's
bloody good
very nice the dancing by reminds us of a
good time we had it broke
[ __ ] this is a reference
is that a giant butt spider
it's coming closer and i don't like it
all right we're going for the spider oh
my [ __ ] god
kill
[Music]
jesus
oh my god
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i'm half a heart jesus i didn't
notice
[ __ ]
uh we're just gonna have to spawn it
ah the traps
i died no i pooped died
oh what what did i do what did i do i
didn't click on purpose i
have that what oh i can't do this on the
emulator version can i
zero the hips oh it works okay it works
okay
come on serve that zero that serve that
no
okay
it's the generous game
oh my god don't die again
[Music]
oh god i'm gonna die nope
not today
oh god it's a stupid poisonous one i
hate them
[ __ ] i didn't see him i saw him as soon
as he hit me
sarah devs come on sarah devs come on
is there this
okay that's probably the worst one you
can get
oh you're so cute
dude the nuggets are great look at them
go
[Music]
nearly there oh i was finding a my
second reference
butt sac toy nice
what do i do with that i can probably
give it to edgar right
okay so let's kill this
we get a scroll nice
oh i can't go there
no oh it breaks my heart
i can afford a new upgrade eh
you're definitely a bright spot in my
day periods keep up the great work just
rewatch the ghost of sushi machine love
that game and also if you haven't
checked out the other
uh casa ichigo you definitely should
i've read two of his works actually
never let me go i think it's called and
the giant something yes okay
i like never let me go it was weird
[ __ ] i gotta walk back uh oh oh is he
here okay
worst timing
oh i was hit by a you're right but i
didn't say you're right back
what it mean
half a heart felix don't die let your
poop die yeah
you can make more poop it's okay
we showed up we beat private mate just
have to give some contract boring stuff
what happens when you get money you
spend your days signing contract
okay where the [ __ ] and playing games
for a living i'm not complaining
uh okay i know where i need to go but it
looks like
there's stuff here and i want it
oh can it make any more spike boobs
fox safe
and then how do i go where do i go here
it is
oh my [ __ ] gone don't die
that was too close
damn boys
oh there were traps i didn't see the
traps
playing games we're living in some life
yeah they say they couldn't be done
they said it couldn't be done but look
at where i am now mama
maybe your game not going to get me
anywhere ma'am oh [ __ ] my god damn it
spin zero that's
there that's
i'll take it
go go go don't go in the trap don't
bring the [ __ ] thank you
[Music]
oh it's spawner [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
get the spawner mate there we go make
another poop
[Music]
we're good we're good one dine rest in
chat
i've been watching you since i was in my
mom's womb
and now i'm nine we loved it from abu
dhabi
abu dhabi thank you that's some hardcore
[ __ ] i appreciate that
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm hungry again what time is that port
epic
[Music]
contemplating snack
[Applause]
oh gosh we're going in
come on minions faster they're frozen
let's go
i tried the boxing first time yesterday
i bought a
double dublin bag is that where it's
called
i was walking about mate don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm doing but
i wanted to try a different type of
exercise
doubling ball
got me sweating i don't [ __ ] know
[Music]
so yeah i'll be fighting ksi any day now
i think my neighbor said that he's into
boxing he was like you fighting ksi next
i'm like no
[ __ ] way i'll die and i don't want to
fight him anyway
[Music]
here we go
i personally prefer unboxing nice boss
battle
oh god [ __ ] i don't think i ever made it
this far
or did i uh
let's go let's oh
not my poops like that you did not
they do so much damage let's go
no no they're poison no my minions
get the poop socks get the stuff
[ __ ] i got poop i got poop
more poops more poops more poops
more poops we're good
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's the best game
[Music]
let's go
welcome despicable sam room has hidden
his lair behind a locked gate
samurai's spell is too powerful for you
and your minions to force it open
but if there is a lock you could
possibly make a key
ask bum down for badly
[Applause]
find samurai ask bummed off advice
ask for his advice mate you got we be
advising me
[Music]
oh i can attack them now [ __ ] have i
just not been clicking on them properly
before
because they dropped so much good stuff
i want that good stuff
got my arm a bit big with a fortune
[ __ ]
[Music]
voice acting hundred thank you thank you
i try i really do
we're nearing uh
[Music]
end of chapter one um
master broken
you know what since there's no ads
i already bought it okay sure
oh that's why i'm not getting ads okay
save game
and let's go to brotan
wait we need to go here
let's try it
yeah it's this way i need a snack i'm
going to be right back
i'm hungry
i was muted i was [ __ ] me
new use of slash coming out today baby
that's what i said basically
all right i'm opening up a fresh one
oh that snap always get me
the first pop always the greatest
oh oh so
it's you feel smells good i don't think
you should smell it because it's powder
and it might go into your lungs but
it smells good
[ __ ] i'm spilling all over the place
here we go legendary moments
oh yeah get that in there that's nice
oh oh 30
off it comes out in 30 minutes
and if you enter code pewdiepie you get
30 off baby
give it a shikarooni
do a line of g-field
i don't i won't recommend that either
it is sweet it's not it's like sour
sweet
which is nice
so good
can we heal no all right
let's continue mate
yeah let's go
uh the flavor is called uses slash baby
what is this collectible item
ah poor fella heal him
what color is it yellow what it's yellow
and green my
g fueling lungs optimal usage
[Music]
did i get to choose it yeah just like
the other one
no game sound sorry
[Music]
i forgot to eat my snack as well so
[Applause]
now i just have to hear people telling
me no game sound for like a minute
[Music]
four colors to drink yellow yellow
greenish
yellow you guys want to see
caller g field review
[Music]
and spell it all on my people
[Applause]
here have a sip bro take a sip bro
place your face on the screen bro here
you go
[Music]
it's good right and now you get 30
up
just having a wee bit of nuts mate
[Music]
don't judge how i eat
[Applause]
[Music]
right
abort
[Music]
how was that mmm sorry
well user is japanese lemon so it should
be but it's sweeter
[Music]
nothing wrong with some nuts in the
mouth thanks guys
erasing flavor yeah
that actually sounds gross how's it
moving very busy
thank you
[Music]
oh god don't all get poisoned
sweet lemonade
i'll explain perfectly how it tastes
like
because they wrote it down for me
to me it's it it's sweet lemonade yeah i
think that fits
but what they say
[Music]
yuzu citrus genus is a hybrid citrus
fruit
also known as yuja yuja
it originated in china over thousands of
years ago
a thousand years ago now grows in japan
korea and other parts of the world
fresh yuzu has a citrusy tart flavor
that could best be described as a mashup
of grapefruit
lemon and mandarin that actually makes
perfect sense
reading it i wouldn't be able to explain
it myself
but there you go
[Music]
sweet lemonade sounds redundant get that
[ __ ]
where's my knife you know what
go go to school how did you get your
thumb
[Music]
several images do you feel here
including pewter's flavor you're a lucky
son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah i'll shoot you with a knife
oh my god stop dying
you know i'll just tankies
[Applause]
oh god he got this these suck i hate
them
[Music]
yeah an american store said they sell it
not everyone
but i think retail needs to roll out
like progressively
but [ __ ] it'd be so cool to see
do you feel at a store pewdiepie the
competitors
i don't like them i may be biased but i
don't like them
oh god you're all gonna die hope you're
proud of death
can't buy do you feel in mexico oh god
bless you i'm so sorry to hear that
night
that's [ __ ] up what's wrong with
mexico why they do this
[Music]
it was so weird uh i went to a summer
lemon in canada
and i was i'm only used to like the
japanese 7-eleven
and going to the canadian one it's so
[ __ ]
like bruh how can it be so different
it's the same company
here we go it would seem that i only
briefly escaped the affairs of worms and
butters
well legend says there's a spell
summoning the key for every lung
the magic recipe is hitting in the
forgotten village infested with poop
slugs
bring it to me and i will help you find
poop slug neck
hell no wait
excuse me
[ __ ] the chairs
stop dying
[Music]
nice
secret
so which way was it i thought it sent to
the right
yeah it is
[Music]
oh god look at this
there's so many
all right we're gonna go out all out
bless then
jesus christ mate get the spawners mate
get their spawners they're already
[ __ ] him up
what's attacking me
god damn
[Music]
game gets really tough
oh come on
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah die
oh they're fighting the nuggets i might
as well attack them
the nuggets are strong bloody crazy
might
or not game a
chat went dead yeah i was looking over
and nothing to say
[Music]
no don't go there don't go there leads
kill them
and then we go
[Music]
thoughts i'm playing do me turn dude you
rest that like five times bro
uh i don't know
you drink g fuel with a straw fancy
fancy paints
[Music]
which way is it here
let's go
what the blood i shoot no
kill it
oh what
[Music]
come back
i'd hide poopies
stop it stop it
[Music]
kill it kill
oh my [ __ ] god i hate them
[Music]
nice i need that thank you nugget
come on come on babe
yes sweet vengeance
he's gotta kill him fast
[Music]
oh god i'm slow down
okay one day gotta kill this son of a
[ __ ]
call him back there it is
[Music]
uh happy birthday to chu papi
money yo what a name happy birthday
you snort she fell into there all right
you do what you want with it
i prefer drinking
i should probably freeze them tonight
freeze
pause
speaking of morgs i saw that he quit to
then just
come back
what
oh my [ __ ] god freeze falls
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die i'm gonna
oh that was so close
[Music]
it's a spawner in it
damn it
damn boys nope
all right i'm going through [ __ ] this i
can't i have to kill them okay
[Music]
um
there you go kill them
[Applause]
[Music]
it's boys me to go up here though
i don't think i can
[Music]
how much is this game it's free baby
go download bros
[Music]
oh dodge that clean baby
is this still moving i don't know what
the [ __ ] he's up to
[Music]
oh bless the nuggets the poop nuggets
dead
thoughts i'm playing doing maternal i
don't know ask me again in five minutes
oh my [ __ ] god give me the free spell
please
come back
[Music]
what's the recipes
you have to go to town but i don't want
it i don't wanna
oh my gosh they followed me
[Applause]
there it is you're all dead
thank gosh oh there's more
oh my god
they are so awful i hate them
the poison kill them come on
[Music]
this is mental mate
press the button click the button
there we go all right
feels better man
[Music]
i love how he does that oh god not these
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god no
it's a massacre
kill him kill him
[Music]
i'll fart all day if i have to kill him
i should really go to town
didn't apple ban this yeah they brought
it back
they sure took their time huh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[ __ ] i have one poop left make a count
okay i take hint
i take him i go back
fine
[Music]
talking about cheese and g fuel yes
thanks chad keep it up
chad yes i do
give me stuff yes more
thank you edgar you're the best
[Music]
all right give me scrolls
let's get this
[Music]
there we go now we're stocked up baby
how's that going doing he's doing great
i hear it's just getting cuter and cuter
i swear
[Music]
i'm less annoying tim not gonna lie
this is where we came from
[Music]
i got strong's poop now i don't want to
lose him
you don't have to go to town for
shopping see i knew i can't i don't have
to but i don't know how
[Music]
uh excuse me my game i think i know
better
die
there we go thank you
thank god okay
[Music]
oh another one
oh my gosh
[Music]
kilam
it looks like a ball sack thing
supposed to be a butt
[Applause]
die
this opponent what
this is a bonus area is what i was
trying to say there bruce
yeah ready to get book signing harry
potter
best that's theirs
another bonus area okay another bonus
area bros
let's check it can't fake it
can't make it seem like it was purpose
so we get a crystal if we do this oh
[ __ ] that i ain't doing it
[Music]
uh
i can't
[Music]
die okay
oh my gosh oh it's a boss one
oh no oh no
what the [ __ ] is all this then
let me poop god damn it oh disastrous
consequences retreat retreat
retreat retreat
[ __ ] i only have three poops left it was
[ __ ] up mate
[Music]
all right followed me
there we go kill him kill him
kill him
kill them oh they're so slow
kill the spawner
kill their homes the women and children
too
no wait oh gosh
i kill this oh god it's so ugly
no
[Music]
yes we got the recipe
let's go i'm out adios
this is it we hit the magic recipe farts
parts in the teeth
you didn't hide it good enough mate
give me that i'm full health never mind
don't eat it
okay so where do we go now
let's get this
holes
i hate them
[Music]
killed them killed them
what's in here
what's all this thing oh i'll take it
give it kill the chairs
[Music]
nice to freeze i like that i like that a
lot
definitely worth looking around
give me that was a morgue's paws yes
thank you frank the iconic the one and
only morgue's free spell that's what we
should call it
morgue's parts please hell yeah
[Music]
okay now where we go i don't know
here where are we then
[Music]
it's like a reverse pooping ill
don't say that
[Music]
oh it's marzia every day i'm chilling
with despair today 92 years it passed
and my little brother went missing
my boneless body is too old to let me
collect the flares for the individual
oh the little fat nutty hurry up how
fast girl today
wow rude marzia why does she have two
buttholes
explain yourself so you found it yeah
the dog was right you you truly are
fearless
i'm going to my bisbee enemy table
collect flowers from etsy
that's her little brother jack what
martial's little brothers jack poop deep
pie
i can't believe it she isn't destroying
too bad as for him
92 92 uh bros
92 [ __ ] mate
get the [ __ ] out all right
all right then better get cracking then
mate
[Music]
it says this way
ah
[Music]
you got the shaker oh it should be out
now it's five
cheese to you mate
here's the flower place at last
or was it there was something on the
left
oh this is so relaxing and nice
cute
oh you just collect flowers
that's so sweet
love it
[Music]
and we're back
oh it's it's freeze time
oh
[Music]
how do i enter discount code i assume in
checkout you just enter pewdiepie
or actually i'm i think you might need
to use a link
try g fuel.com pewdiepie
uh i have the link in today's video it's
coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
as soon as i'm done with this live
stream
how long i've been live three hours damn
time flies hey
[Music]
[Applause]
so we just need to collect flowers here
really boom
[ __ ]
[Music]
you should get our 92 flowers in real
life damn
our anniversary is coming up that would
be a move wouldn't it
kind of like this loki
[Music]
yeah i didn't see darma's video about me
i talked about it earlier
i just thought it was funny
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys cop the cup hell yeah
enjoy it
treat it with dignity and respect that
it deserves
[Music]
i don't think i need to use that for
whatever
god damn they get strong
[Music]
we're diversifying go forth my army
you like that voice acting in the
trailer
yeah it wasn't cringe at all okay cool
go ahead glad you think so thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you how do you cope with all these
years everyone wants your attention
your attention giver meter must be over
nine thousand
mate don't even get me stop hey
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
i think um yeah it can be really
annoying to be honest because i value
my own time a lot
[Music]
there's always someone like kind of like
yanking at you like hey but you could do
this for me
help me do this you're successful and
stop do this
please thank you i will like it
alright leave me alone
oh my gosh there we go
let's deal with these [ __ ] rooms
goated game
it's longer than i remember [ __ ] me
chapter two coming up
give attention please it also i
i mean i've gotten past this now i think
i watched a podcast where markiplier was
in i think it was with
defranco and mark said that he always
feel like he's an [ __ ]
because there's always people that want
his attention and i could relate to that
but i'm way past feeling bad about it at
this point
[Music]
but i can definitely relate to that
because everyone wants something from
you all the time and you feel it bad
because you have to obviously prioritize
certain things
and it makes you feel like you are an
[ __ ] for either shutting
people out or whatever it is you gotta
[Music]
do
i'm just collecting flowers no big deal
with poop
very nice i like it
[Music]
[Applause]
it ain't so bad
but i do think if there's ever a reason
for me to not do youtube anymore it
would just be for people to leave me
alone
yeah i think that makes sense
[Music]
i think i also need to make choices
better
[Music]
i don't know if any of this makes sense
i'm just having an internal monologue
uh you should better be epic
goddamn or else i'm telling 2018 kids
hey hold up
while i describe the flavor okay you
tell me
[Music]
if that that's your thing or not
where do i need to go
we're learning the crap out of this
[Music]
did i not do this
i don't know where to go
[Music]
oh yeah we're just collecting flowers
i'm not going anywhere i forgot
[Music]
it's a great area great idea
can i see how many flowers i have i have
91. how many was it 92
yeah there you go [ __ ]
[Music]
all right then
okay we just need to go to the exit
which is up here
then i think we're ready for the last
fight
[Music]
it just occurred to me imagine having to
pull the hair out of the shower drain
that felix has been using
why are you thinking about that jim
explain yourself
[Music]
i actually cleaned the shower drain
today so that weighs me out even more
than you said that
[Music]
there you go anger
what is the quality
[Music]
explosive parts now
now
[ __ ] all right they do more damage then
there you go marcelia
[Music]
will look lovely in the crazy sorry i
lifted you before
same time you're so conservatively
sanders you're finally leaving that
movie i know the feeling bro don't even
stress it bro
all right i click here i forgot okay
uh
what am i trying to do i'm trying to buy
a time card and we're going here
angelic voice acting for the way thank
you
oh my tiny hero
yesterday you were bathing in a part of
your own tears and today
you wiped away the taste of old martial
none of your hearts tremble in fear of
the monsters of the
underground's bog speed
bug speed indeed
[Music]
thank you for having me let me conjure
the spell i can feel the poop key being
created this is so gross dude
it is truly an unexpected feeling it
comes
hell all right
uh because this one covers
less of the screen you see more of this
face you know me
i'm so sorry please help me
oh my god really they set me up with a
trap right away
oh god they're gonna spread now
let's just go for it mate
are there any traps i don't see
fam try not to cringe either edition or
not much cringe this year i actually i
was on holiday so i didn't catch it
but y'all y'all tell me if there was
because i i don't know
i don't see him there he is
[Music]
have you finished hanging these i'm
pretty sure i finished every
single ending of that i had so much fun
playing hades
that was like the best lockdown game i
[Music]
had
that was close
it was cringe city no way all right i'll
check it out love me some good cringe
thank you dina it's coming
oh it's freeze time [ __ ]
it's really nice to play this on pc i
gotta say i thought it would be awkward
but
it works totally fine
we definitely gonna explode here mate
there's breath of the wild too they
announced that
that's my mom's favorite game the first
one
she's still playing she's still playing
it
even though she's beating it so many
[Music]
times
she says she loves games that have a
good feeling
i mean it's a legit good game
she ain't wrong though
so i was like but mom you got to play
animal crossing i think you love it
and she's like no they sound so annoying
when they speak
i can't get past it
[Music]
he said exactly like that yet
nope come back come back come back come
back
you're right i keep hearing that i know
that's not what they're saying
freeze [ __ ]
[Music]
wow
i'm not sure where i'm going
i should try and start dividing i don't
think that's not her kind of games i
don't know why
i thought she would love the super mario
the one on the switch what was called
odyssey
because i enjoyed that almost more than
right through the while
how is brighton don't even ask how
dare you
the only game my mom plays is mario kart
hell yeah
based mom
is the game on mobile as well no the
game is for mobile
it's for android and ios i'm just
emulating it
which honestly works if you wanted to
play it on pc
[ __ ]
this is easier to stream it this way
instead of trying to set up a
you know know how it is
what's attacking me oh there it is
oh god not these i hate them
freeze balls
[Music]
next time you could show us your room on
the
youtube simulator what
i don't understand
[Music]
[Applause]
the freezes god bless it love it
press the button i didn't catch e3 now
i just watched that um elder ring
whatever the [ __ ] it was called
[Music]
hmm
room tour still waiting for another
closet review you want to see all my
black t-shirts that i have
eggmaster i yo
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] up
where the hell am i going
ah here we go
i swear the poops are saying yoshi
you're still on that come on
it's poopy oh my lord
oh freeze
[Music]
oh gosh
oh it's going to poison all of them [ __ ]
[Music]
don't die oh no
okay we got a lot of scrolls here nice
getting ready for the last battle
i have a lot of scrolls i can heal a lot
i never have to poop again
yeah i'm still planning for japan of
course i'm
like 99 percent
oh i should just use extra fart on those
of course
there's nine plus 10 at 21.
21 like that
it's a disaster mate
[Applause]
oh they're all gonna die
i mean i don't have to go there actually
it was a long time ago but wasn't their
way to cure maybe i haven't gotten the
upgrade
[ __ ] we lost the fallen poop
[Music]
died
oh hello
oh my god they all got poison seriously
where can i buy the stock market for
this game want to buy it out and become
king
well i mean poop coins might take off
next crypto we were talking about it
who knows
i think considering how much
we got
have you had any crazy dreams involving
any games lately
no but i had a really strangely
comfortable dream
[Music]
what was it oh i uh everything
it was like a weird dystopia i lived in
where everything was super modern but
also really old
like the classic likes what's it called
not cyberpunk
where's the cyberpunk
uh no it isn't what the [ __ ] is it
called
and i kept eating ice cream it was great
great dream thanks for asking
here we go
[Music]
i know your heart is thumping remember
it doesn't matter what we're going to
find on the other side
i'm always with you thank you
[Music]
you're a real one uh it all comes down
to this
oh my god
no not like
this
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that
[Applause]
is that what i think it is i don't i'm
scared
oh god take cover poops
oh my lord we're gonna have to deal with
these
chief says oh
no kill him
kill him
kill him you're strong
you're brave oh god ill
go oh god
[Music]
oh god damn it
almost there it is
oh god oh no i knew it wasn't over
oh he's got a septic guy that son of a
[ __ ]
it's a gross avocado maybe you shall
return to your pond of tears
[Applause]
[ __ ] you i mean
non-copyright version kill him
[Applause]
kill him
more dpas more poopy as i mean
oh no we lost one
kill
[Applause]
yes
half a third okay one more let's go
is there a shower level well maybe in
chapter two coming up
it's out i mean but
[Music]
that looks like testicles come on
friends with your own excrement you
disgust me
oh no oh
no
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] yeah i'm friends with my own
[ __ ]
problem xd
oh there's trapped as well oh jesus
oh god we're taking damage oh god
oh i'm gonna die
not like this at least they drop a lot
of stuff
jesus christ
[Applause]
there it is there it is mate oh god it's
still alive
[ __ ] come back ill
poop
oh my gosh
i can't freeze them i'm almost dead
[Applause]
attack this thing then
i like that sound not gonna lie
get out of there no all my pumps are
there i have one foot
poop like you've never pooped come on
baby
oh attack
[Music]
i like that i like that i like that
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] oh my pups are dead oh that was
so that was way too close
okay now i gotta poop like a poop oh god
[ __ ] this is difficult
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
where is he attack
come on
i don't have any poops left
[Music]
no
okay i'll i'll i'll spin so that's there
that's covered there there's
that okay i have one heart now
and shitty poops
are all my poops dead
oh my [ __ ] god this is so difficult
[Applause]
okay i can't afford a good food
for [ __ ] sake they're all dying
[Applause]
i died oh i didn't see that at all
okay gamer face on zero that's come on
zero then
whenever i never get sealed dabs
oh my god oh this is so difficult
there it is there there
i don't spin it good enough
oh my god it's landing on me
[Applause]
yes i'll spin but give me zero damage
there ready stop killing me stop
oh my god he's gonna land on me
i don't have time to poop there we go
[Applause]
got this all right we're going here i'm
gonna freeze you
i'm gonna poop oh god he's gonna land on
me
another poop another poop we need more
poop more poop
buff them attack
almost we're so close jesus christ
i have zero poops brows
[Music]
two poops three poops
four poops
five poops this is huge buff the poops
charge
[Music]
zero dash i did the whole game
boy
[Applause]
yeah hell
forgive me for have been confused seems
like evil samurai messed up my magic
recipe
please take this king which i crafted
for you oh
thanks bro
[Music]
thanks so much
wow that was one
hell of a battle ain't gonna lie
oh my god it poisoned my poop goddammit
here we go poopty
was perplexed best voice acting he was
about to face xamarin's malevolence
and grounds would never be the same
again malevolence i said it simply put
the pooper key
into the pooper hole and twisted it
why am i laughing suddenly
a gentle breeze blew the dirt away and a
horrific truth
was unearthed our heroes stood
speechless
at the wizards footstep not even a
single fart
what are the other ones am i laughing
clear i didn't foresee the strength of
the spam
i changed some voice for him somehow
there are three keyholes
he sounds like a true smeagol and time
itself
but where they ask themselves
none of them knew that in the west a new
threat was rising
its sinister hand
so a real adventure was about to not
real
chapter two baby chapter two
[Music]
blind man from the swamp it begins
we need more we will need two more tears
to enter the terror
head to the stinky swamp and find brian
now oh the wisest of our goblin bits
may be able to help us
[Music]
hey all right so we unlock chapter two
here which is the new
part of the game check out poopy
it's free it's lit only free right
lit early comes with a bottle oh
all right that's it for today
feeling lonely without a group and you
can't go
to the zoo need to go to the
[ __ ] zoo
i got don't be dumb but you
and it with that bit like
[Music]
hell yeah check it out
next time we'll do chapter two
thanks for uh joining a bro rooney's
bronies should i call you that bro
rooney
yes yes i'll call you that
it's fun hanging out thanks for joining
guys
all the best until next time
rufus oh yeah new yuzu
i'm up